er betting squad ride presented by
giraffe kings live in the bleacher
report app my name is connor rogers
alongside the man of the people he's not
done giving away things he's just
getting started that is greg ivory greg
i think you gave away about 20 hoodies
last week you need to top that number
today you got any left
connor i have an abundance left actually
in fact i'm going to give out one right
now for the new people for the new
people in the back for the new people
that's joining the show this right here
connor you want to tell them what this
is that is the handy dandy ipad my man
this right here is the handy dandy ipad
and this is how you get your hoodies
this is how you get your jerseys this is
how you get tapped into the show i'm in
the comments connor i am in the comments
and i see uh
daniel levi daniel levi has the alvin
kamara gift going it's right there the
alvin kamara give going shout out to my
guy daniel levi you are walking away
with the hoodie connor let's get this
show on the road man people forget you
gave away a trip to las vegas on that
thing so you never know what's going to
come about but this is the show where
you never know this is the show where we
bet anytime touchdown scores chosen by
you the squad and last week we rode with
riley sorbo and derek henry the king led
us down shockingly no end zone for derek
henry i think we're gonna make up for
that today with what we got in store on
friday we asked you on social we asked
you in the app to drop your locks to
score a touchdown here's the most
popular picks you sent us no surprise at
the top it's expected to be a big day
for the browns against the houston
texans so nick chubb sitting there alvin
kamara against the panthers christian
mccaffrey we know what he can do travis
kelsey against a depleted ravens team
can he get going ezekiel elliott can he
get back on track same with jonathan
taylor and then george kittle and
staphon diggs two excellent pass
catching
weapons all right we got a ton of great
videos from you last week obviously we
can't feature them all but here are a
few of our favorites that we haven't
gotten to show you yet
up it's game day i'm gonna spend this
football and we'll find out all right
good girl go get it got a bunch of
players here about to find out who
scores
justin jefferson
[Music]
good girl and josh allen for the lock
[Music]
james robinson anytime score let's go
baby lock it in christian mccaffrey
keenan allen anytime touchdown score
plus 120. good luck boys
[Music]
you gotta love it greg we know you got
the hoodies but we're taking things up a
notch this season what else you got in
store
that's right connor i'm not only giving
out hoodies but i'm also giving away two
not one but two nfl jersey gift cards uh
one is going to the winner of the lock
legend contest that we're gonna do and
the other is going to a commenter so
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and do what you do
if you need a jersey if you need a
hoodie
i need gifts i need emojis i need
comments and most importantly connor
most importantly i need winners only
please that's right all right we have
please or legend please all right we
have four legendary picks to show you as
always the last one standing
is the leader of the squad and that
person that player gets an odds boost on
draftkings so you want to stick around
to the end and hammer that odds boost
it's time for round one and who better
to start with than the defending champ
the reigning squad leader that is riley
sorbo riley tell us who's scoring a
touchdown today
last week derek henry couldn't get it
done for us but we went 4-0 last year on
the farm so we're back on the farm we've
got dalvin cook and we've got george
kittle charlie
help us out buddy
come on
which one do you want
oh
oh what do you got what did you get
george tiddle george kittle lock it in
let's go good boy
good boys only please back on the farm
all right we got it we got to get our
first decision of the day here the
second legend this one comes from w
trammell what do you got w trammell
vr nation anytime touchdown scored let's
see what we can
alvin kamara lock it in
love the br branding on the balloons all
right you heard the first two pitches
here greg who are you riding with you
got charlie on the farm the good boy
legend essentially or the balloon
legend connor before i give my take what
i need everybody in the comments to do
is tell us who you are riding with are
you riding with riley in the red legend
riley or are you riding with
trammell my guy w trammell the balloon
legend with alvin kamara uh but let me
talk about these videos a little bit uh
connor riley is back on the farm as he
mentioned he is 4-0 on the forum car and
he is back on the form
so i like that right there i like that
right there also
that dog is trying to get bragg like
everybody here the people in the
comments connor i'm pretty sure you're
trying to get to the bread and i'm
trying to get to the bread so the dog
got to the bread shout out to you riley
you are once again a legend and i love
the george kettlepig love the george
kettlepick
the balloon legend the branding a1 the
balloon the bucket legends are back they
were here last week conor now they're
back the bucket legends they're back
they're leveling up this week they're
leveling up this week with the slo-mo
video they put a little production into
this they put a little bit of production
into this with the slow-mo video alvin
kamera pick okay i like it but i'm
leaning towards george kettle i'm
leaning towards george kettle love the
bread reference love riley on the farm
he's 4-0 so that's where i'm rocking
with who are you rocking with carter man
i love dogs and i love the george kittle
pick right that is plus money right
there i'm a sucker for the branding the
br branding the balloon legend going
with alvin kamara but guess what greg
it's not up to me it doesn't matter what
i think what are the people deciding
right now
connor i'm back into the handy dandy and
the comments are moving at a fast pace
uh i got san francis says san francis
hunter says kittle all the way 49ers you
know that is going to get my attention
therefore you were walking away with the
hoodie uh
i'm moving on i am moving on i see husta
must
in the comments saying he says the
people's champ the people's champ oh
that's george kittle because you know he
likes to to be the people's champ yeah
the people's tied in shout out to you
hustler mutts he's rocking with george
kettle hey connor
the next one i choose i'm just gonna i'm
like i'm just gonna say that they're
winning i'm just gonna announce that
they win okay
just so you guys don't think that i'm
biased just because you just so you guys
don't think that i'm biased i'm gonna
pick the nine i'm just gonna scroll and
then wherever i land we're going to rock
with it here we go three two one scroll
bam kamara
obp19 you're walking away with a hoodie
he got the alvin kamara gif right here
you guys see it right there uh oh let me
get it up a little bit
there it is i'm a kamara gift obp
one nine your walk away with a hoodie
therefore
my guy w trammell is moving on
to the next round shout out to alvin
kamara minus 175. we're gonna change
that yeah hopefully we flip that w
trammell with the upset against the
reigning king and riley sorbo hopefully
riley is back next week with charlie but
moving on only two challengers remain
let's get into round two our next pitch
comes from mark benna who you got
[Music]
[Music]
the racing legend going with travis
kelsey man i got to get one of those in
my house that's how you decide
everything i love the ponies in this one
right now greg are you going with the
racing legend are we sticking with the
balloons
i need everybody to tell us who's going
to win this part this portion of the
contest i need everybody in the comments
to tell me should i rock with the race
legend or the balloon legend but i'll
give my take on the race legend conor we
have never seen this before this was
actually entertainment
but i i i'm just that number five horse
looks like he might have been on peds
connor the way he got out the blocks
we might need to uh send somebody out
there to go test them but uh travis
kelsey
patrick mahomes is my fantasy
quarterback so there's a connection
there there's a connection there so i'm
leaning towards the race legend i like
the video and i like the pick what are
you thinking connor i'm right there with
you love this pick think travis kelsey
scores at least once on sunday night
football i love the ponies man i love
this concept like you said hadn't seen
it before it's creative i think we do
need to start having a little you know
ped test regulation here if that one
keeps winning
but once again not up to me do the
comments have a favorite does the
balloon legend get knocked off in round
number two
let me find out
connor i got c
low 0 3 2 3 with the travis kelsey gift
it just went away so i can't show you
guys but he picked travis kelsey i also
got g h guns burger guns burger spelt
with a gh uh that's for the producers he
has the travis kelsey gift dancing as
well shout out to you guns burger you
are walking away with the hoodie uh
connor i think it's time to make a
decision big mike big mike 13 says
travis kelsey he says travis kelsey he
has the travis kelsey gift uh yeah yeah
the comments are moving i can't even
show you guys the gifts the comments are
moving uh connor i think i'm making a
decision here i think it's apparent
my guy mark benja
and travis kelsey is moving on to the
next round i think it was made easy for
you made it easy for us mark benham
moving on the ponies moving on travis
kelsey maybe getting an odds boost this
week but he's got to defeat our final
contender to not only be the squad ride
leader but to take home the jersey if
you want a jersey stick around because
we got one more to give away as well all
right winner of this round takes all
next up last up is oscar parkinson oscar
let's see the pick can you close this
out
all right guys my props just finished
hooking up let's see what we got
these are sizzling
[Applause]
all right dallas
what do we got
zeke 80 yards yeah no
arizona
k murray 50 rush yards no
green bay what do we got
d adams 90 yards in
not after last week
this guy's crispy carolina
cmc anytime td lock right here guys cmc
lock it in
don't forget your oven mitts next time
oven legend absolutely love
what he's cooking up and love the picks
cmc travis kelsey both minus 150 so that
means you're getting a good boost
somewhere you're getting it somewhere
greg which way do you want this one to
go
connor
i gotta ask the people in the audience
first
you guys we got
travis kelsey
christian mccaffrey
which way are you guys leaning you like
the race legend do you like the oven
legend let me hop in here on the oven
legend connor i'm not gonna lie i'm a
little bit uh
i don't even know the word that i'm
trying to say but i just thought that i
was gonna see something tasty i thought
that i was gonna see something sizzling
coming out the oven but i saw
helmets
so uh i don't know how i feel about that
i don't know how i feel about that i
think i'm still leaning towards this
travis kelsey and the race legend and
the peds of this horse that just was out
the blocks really fast so i think i'm a
lean this way conor which way are you
leaning i'm going to be honest with you
i'm comfortable sitting on the fence
here i'm good with either of these
getting boosted i think both of these
guys scored this week whichever one wins
i'll happily hammer travis kelsey on
sunday night football cmc against the
saints you know darnold's going to be
checking it down to him all day
let's let the people decide greg who is
going to be the squad ride leader of
week two
connor let me tap into the handy dandy
let me tap into the handy danny and hey
i mean i'm seeing a lot and i mean a lot
of your guy
cmc i got
i-s-h-a-i that's for the producers uh
rocking with cmc gave me the cmc uh gift
that i if i show i'm pretty sure it's
gonna like there it is back to back you
guys see it two cmcs right there uh
shout out to daniel gutman2 you are you
two are walking away with the hoodie um
i'm gonna give away one more connor one
more i got chris paul goat chris paul go
got the cmc gift going connor it is a
landslide in the comments i am seeing a
cmc gifts landslide literally landslide
in the comments i'm seeing cmc gifts cmc
uh comments uh yeah okay yeah we're
we're making the call there we're making
the call
over
the oven legend the oven legend
is winning today's
uh today's contest i mean he won the the
people have spoken so shout out to cmc
and the oven legend let's see the
graphic cause i have to show you guys
something i have to show you guys
something that us
here on the squad ride something that we
can do only uh you guys see that right
there it says -150 connor let me show
you some magic poof
let me show you some magic poo there it
is there it is you see you guys saw that
it just changed to plus 100 uh thanks to
our friends at draft keys we're going to
boost that for you guys from minus 150
to plus 100 check the br betting social
score link to the odds boost send us
your screenshots of your bets send us
your videos of your celebrations
we want winners and winners only please
let's go man that just pumped me up
that's beautiful on the show love it
beautiful sight when you get cmcf plus
money i absolutely love it that's a big
boost last week derek henry minus 150
this week cmc plus money and we are not
done we got more locks to give we got
more bold bets you got hoodies you even
got a jersey where's this jersey going
to go i can't wait all right if you hang
out in the br betting community whether
it's in the app whether it's on social
you know what we ask you in the app we
want your boldest bets we want and last
week we had what calvin ridley wide
receiver
leader of the season titans coming out
on top of the afc didn't look so good
week one that's why they're bold bets
these aren't coward bets these are
having a good time so we picked some of
our favorite comments and we want to
know what you think
greg let's see what the people had to
say for week two
yeah i need you guys to get in the
comments and tell me which of these is
the best take
i'm gonna give a hoodie to whomever you
guys choose uh i'm gonna show you guys
three comments i'm going to show you
guys three comments this week and first
is my guy matt
dadford
first is matt dadford let's
pull it up there it is
uh matt dafford says
that my wife comes back home plus nine
thousand
long good luck matt i'm gonna sing you
i'm gonna send matt a hoodie i'm gonna
send my hoodie just to keep you warm at
night next up is kyle
kyle one three two three says packers
continue to struggle and move oh
sizzling i don't know about that one
yeah yeah yeah
and finally we got raider909
says derek carr for another
plus yards three touchdowns against the
steelers defense what are you kidding me
raider909
i mean gosh connor
what's which take do you think is the
best i'm over here sweating reading
909's coming oh man we said we said bold
bets not insane but uh listen that
steelers defense
i'm sorry i know they're a raider fan
coming off a fun week i i hope it
happens for you but i think you would
even just take a win or a cover at that
point 400 yards and three touchdowns is
darren waller gonna have 300 of them i'm
not loving that i already said the wife
to come home plus nine thousand i'm
sorry i'm out on that
it's a big line in the packers game and
they were clearly picking money line
lions if i have to pick one of these
three i'll roll with that it's gonna be
a long rebuild for the lions but dan
campbell we know one thing he has them
ready to play and the packers i think
they bounced back this week but it
looked rough last week so let's go with
the the boldest bet at least from my end
i would go with the boldest bet taking
the lions what what are you thinking
what are the people saying i mean these
are insane do people agree with any of
these
uh ddt says packers go 0-2 so therefore
he is rocking with you connor let me
give him a hoodie ddt if you were
walking away with a hoodie uh
here we go i got neil neal deuce neil
deuce packers pack it in and have a
miserable season go pack go so shout out
to you
uh
they're rocking with they're rocking
with you connor they're walking with you
so therefore uh the winner the winner of
this contest is kyle1323
what the what the packers take so shout
out to you kyle we'll be sending you a
hoodie and shout out to everybody that i
just mentioned
you guys are also walking away with a
hood that's right all right you know you
and i can't stay away from the boldest
bets we take the people's boldest bets
and then we get in on the fun and give
our own boldest bets
i mean this is my favorite time of the
week this is when things get crazy this
is when we need the people the most even
more than the squad ride leaders yes
what do we need from them right now greg
so listen everybody everybody listen up
get in the comments and tell me whether
you're riding with me
or connor so it's greg or connor i need
greg or connor in the comments only we
need to figure out which way are you
guys writing so connor
who do you got this week as your boldest
vet brother greg you know last week i
went with a five leg parlay and it got a
little crazy a couple hit many did not
it's how it goes i got a little
ambitious uh i don't have kids to feed
but still i i'm shaving a little off
because
it was just two nuts we're going to four
leg parlay today this is the long shot
you ready for this let's have some fun
plus 566. that's a big time long shot
but feeling good chase clay pool over
three and a half receptions think he
gets at least four or five against that
raider secondary not worried there
bill's money line is something you and i
have planned all week we've been talking
about this bill's tough week one big
bounce back in miami i like the bills to
win
texans browns over 48. i know people are
not really counting on the texans to do
their scoring part in this one and tyrod
taylor and brandon cooks get enough done
while the browns high powered offense
carries it as well 48 is not a high
number and finally man this should be
the lock of the parlay if this doesn't
hit i don't know what i got to do a
three leg parlay next week broncos money
line over jacksonville like i said those
pass rushers are gonna get home and make
it a tough day for the sensational
rookie trevor lawrence who had a tough
week one he's gonna figure it out i
don't think it's gonna be this week
but i wanna hear yours because i'm a i'm
an addict to this right it's fun with
this one you throw a little money on
let's see what you got as well
i got you connor i got you let's pull up
this graphic please let's pull up this
graphic so i can show the people in the
comments and i can show my guy connor
rogers what we are rocking with today
plus 780
shout out to my guy chad johnson 85.
uh here we go i got the niners taking on
the eagles
i just go get the win y'all i i took the
spread last week they did not cover
against the lions they were up 24 with
like seven minutes left
forget about that we're talking about
this week it's the eagles the eagles
faced the atlanta falcons last week
there's a lot of overreaction on how
they played the niners will handle
business let's move on connor we've been
talking about it buffalo bills we've
been me and you we've been discussing it
since the beginning of this week in fact
we're rocking with it and we're staying
with the buffalo bills moving on to the
cincinnati bengals moving on we don't
even know who's going to be playing
quarterback for the chicago bears i just
got an alert that my guy fields might
take the field today so i don't know
who's going to be playing so therefore
i'm going to rock
with the bengals here because i know
who's going to be playing quarterback
for them
moving on to the saints i'm simply
betting against sam darno i do not think
he's gonna win a game against that
defense me personally i'm betting
against that he's gonna he can win a
game against that saints defense so
there it is i call this the old joe
faithful shout out to joe yan my guide
the old favorites parlay mixed in with
the plus money banger there it is right
there y'all
all right lock it in connor i i love it
man i love it when i get out of here
i'll throw a little on that too we'll
make it fun we'll celebrate together who
are the people riding with and i know
you've got to get rid of this jersey
before we get out of here
connor i mean they were saying greg
before i even gave my pick and then you
know so who they didn't like mine often
jumped yeah
so yeah so i'm gonna just give away some
hoodies just for the vibes and the love
because it's all love here on the
skyrise show uh i got
w-m-b-u-h-l says gregory gregory you
were walking away with a hoodie uh
i then i got uh they're all saying greg
so i'm just trying to read something
here we go all right here geek deep geek
hey shout out to deep geek bro d geek
says connors is better shout out to
finally i got one we got one of a
million away
with a hoodie hey connor guess what it's
time to go away to give away this jersey
man they telling me in my ear giveaway
to jersey just give it away
hey purple and gold
purple and gold 19 has a gift that says
my name on it that's the legendary so
shout out to you
although it's somebody else it's it's
it's it's it's the creativity that i'm
rocking with so therefore
uh purple and gold those are my high
school colors he might have went to my
high school who knows but purple and
gold uh you are walking away with
a jersey my friend pretty good pretty
good man and if you saw those and you
want to get involved we did in the
segment before we got you we'll show
your boldest bets none of this you know
i mean they were crazy derek carr 400
yards three touchdowns a wife coming
back all kinds of things
get involved send us your boldest bets
get in on the action good luck with your
wagers everyone let's make week two a
blast let's make it even better than
week one congrats to all our hoodie and
jersey winners br betting is going to
take care of you they are going to dm
you not greg not me i promise br betting
will not let you down all right
thank you to everyone that commented
makes the show special makes it fun come
back for week three get in on the action
again thanks all our legends riley serbo
making a return w trammell having some
fun mark benna of course we had the
ponies running in this one oscar
parkinson cooking up the good stuff or
maybe he has to step it up and actually
cook some food is what greg is saying
enjoy your football sunday drop your
takes in the sports betting community
stream in the br app and follow us on ig
stories
all day all day alongside greg ivory my
name is
o'connor we cannot get out of here you
already know me someone said connor
rogers my name is greg ivory we cannot
get out of here without giving you guys
hoodies so here we go i'm back into the
comments man easy money 98 y'all rocking
with connor now i'm rocking with greg i
really i didn't even know that they were
going to say this shout out to you
easymoney98 you're walking away with
hoodie uh
here we go duke smith he's rocking with
you connor duke smith you are walking
away with the hoodie here we go one more
connor i got one more in me
oh
that's it actually that's it that's it
yeah that's it that's it he's out he
think he just looked at his stash and
was like i got none left alongside greg
ivory i'm connor rogers see you next
week same time same place
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you